okay uh so
KAG is going to follow everything
exactly of of ago as far as the throwing
architecture goes okay um so you're
you're not going to
do this stuff okay my kids don't even
know how to take that but pretend
you're going to bend backwards for me
and then I
I you're not going to do that okay some
of the things that we pointed out is
remember they have to spinally
displace um the back break fall has to
be going forward I don't push him I I
spiral rotate him into the
throw um
so uh you have to pay attention to all
the ways that you stop their forward
progress um and there's many of them as
I watched all of all of you uh you and
Kathy do the technique so obviously we
have the one with the hand going this
way like you can't go forward if you're
making his hand go backwards you just
can't okay
um but the other one is is this one you
see it's kind
of into into his shoulder
okay it can't be in his it can't be in
his
shoulder uh and he can't make it in his
shoulder that's what also is key
so uh if
I push into his shoulder he could turn
and that's and again no my UK cannot be
allowed to turn okay
there's only two reasons why the UK
turned I turned them and then they're
not having forward progress or the UK
did not per prescription do the forward
progress okay there's the only two ways
um taking that
out if for whatever weird reason my
attacker was so athletic there are those
people out there that even though I got
their Center and I'm turning
them um or or I I'm spiral rotating them
and they can like a cat turn and their
Center you lost the technique you you
have you would abandon that technique
not force that technique okay um very
much like in eeko I said if for whatever
reason the UK's shoulder turned back
towards me then EO opening is done you
don't keep trying for it okay um all
right
so what is what is missing here is
another one of those tactical insights
from fighting
um you are in this technique uh moving
from wrist
control through the elbow to spinal
control just like you did on the ago at
you're looking for the spinal control
um and this is something that is always
present in a lot of the iido techniques
but again people don't don't see it is
you're learning how to go from the grip
to the Head we do this a lot in iido so
one of the most obvious examples that
that I talked about recently is um Berna
was trying to take my
uh footwork here but lack the
understanding the Strategic
understanding of how to move from the
grip to the head but also lacked the ey
key so he couldn't do anything about it
so he he's on the grip and then he's
trying to do the grip again to make him
go and that just doesn't work because he
you'll you'll undo every advantage that
you tried to get originally as you go
through that motion so as I go here you
get more disturbance but as you start to
go through everything goes right back to
where now you can't do it okay you have
to learn to bypass the grid and what
you're doing here is passing his head to
your arm your arm is is adhering and
doing the Sensei yield on the head uh
and then you find the
technique in tension n that's what you
do but on the
inside so this what he's doing here I
pass it to here on that's what I want
okay and now his grip is irrelevant he
can let go it doesn't
matter you not that's the whole point I
don't need your grip I don't want your
grip anymore um and the reason why
that's a point
is if I have a weapon and he grabs it
you're going to make I can't use my
weapon do you see and uh I don't I want
to make his grip ineffective so I go
here and I make the grip in ineffective
okay that that's what you're trying to
do um
so very
similarly as in uh
AO it's just a little more two
dimensionally looking but not really in
terms of functioning when you touch the
chin that is what you're doing
here
well that's exactly what you're doing
instead of touching this chin you bring
him to
here and that's the technique okay
so some key things
don't stop him prescribe him to come
forward don't pull him
backwards and don't try to shove these
shoulders here see we're stuck here okay
and so this is
where the strong do pushes through but
you he would just walk out of it so
we'll come this
way here here he's driving here I'm
driving and if I push through he's he
will he'll be able to move his base back
under as he
goes that's all I got okay
or at that right here at that stale mate
he can turn on you you see and then
you're doing that's not the technique
you lost the technique okay
um I saw the solution you came up with
which is is to bring him to your
shoulder your here on your on your
shoulder okay um but
again that that is just giving you a
long a a shorter lever so it feels more
powerful um where he doesn't have the
distal end advantage over my grip it's
still a
contestation if you did come to the
shoulder you'd still have have to do the
same
yield uh anyways okay to to make that
work um but T net is to here on the AR
on the inner arm so we're going to do
that
drill without the
throw just that
part little f it be behind
yeld
touch
[Music]
Circle okay that in like we're we're
just going to work Virginia's here she's
got a hurt KNE so we're not going to
throw her um but if you can do that then
you understand the tension notet so
we're play for that for a little bit and
then we'll come
back
here
absorb pass there's the pass then the
foot goes out and that's the end of the
Dr h
boom don't bring this this
way because I didn't
enter
so end
Dr so again plot her head in space okay
so her head is still coming this way in
the direction of the spinal displacement
it's still coming this way you see now
don't make it go back the other
way here it's still going forward you
see now she
she I'll show you what you did that okay
so when I go
you see how she came
forward okay you have to stop acting and
that includes protecting so don't
protect your knee you'll feel the energy
going forward can you see that don't pin
your
foot
forward forward no you're pinning your
foot I just threw you that way do you
remember okay so why are you stopping
your foot right now
this is you you feel that
okay this is me you
see so I'd like to make this point for
him we're here there's no reason to pin
your foot your head keeps moving forward
yes you see yes
Bo right
again keep your
R You' B it
again so I want you to understand did
you feel when I chucked you that way yes
I can throw you off the mat with the
first movement yes could you take that
today okay so the energies go on this
way okay don't pain your foot say you
can go backwards cuz I'm never going to
throw you backwards
okay here it is
here this
way you
see feel it we're not going this
way this way
yes
yes okay so now we go back to
him contact we'll use this line here the
north south line
boom We chair head will still go back go
forward
okay don't make her head go
back don't make your head go back okay
try it again
the next thing to
notice
is uh how the yielding is happening the
yielding is not just open he hits it
that that's not what's happening
okay you have this contestation here you
need your elbow
check and this pushes him
forward it's not me getting out of the
way and he falls
forward he want that potential I'm never
going to let him go that that fast but
there's a positive side of the circle
that I am
on the same thing on this other hand
okay it's not that I get out of the way
and he hits it as you saw with
Virginia it
[Music]
throws you do not need the elbow
to do
this you're on the positive side right
there here's where we
are okay then I'm on stay
there this
side
[Music]
driving so that is the
pass it's not me getting out of the way
and he hits my
forarm I am passing him to my right
side this way and he's going to end up
here not here not here not there it's
going to end up right
here so I pass him then I bring him to
it pass him
then bring him to
it outward
spiral inward
spiral then don't contest
[Music]
okay okay now like all of the back break
fall all I need is that little tilt with
energy going forward that's all you
don't need
this and you definitely don't want
that you just need that little tilt with
a
still going
forward then you enter on the x pattern
so when you enter on the x
pattern it's this way and your arm has
to go that
way what is key
however is that they have to work in
conjunction with each other so I'm not
trying to throw him this way
my arm is still doing the same
adhesion which
means it's staying up with his head not
trying to shove his head down and his
head is only going to descend at a r and
at a radius in relation to his Center
going up and
forward okay so you can get you can get
here and then you're
like that's the wrong rate in radius
okay or you can also be very
late that's the wrong radius too so my
arm follows the inward
spiral as the head is in the inward
spiral I don't force it but I don't get
gapped by it either okay and then then
the technique is
effortless I don't shove him down I know
my arm is going down but it's cuz his
head went down his I'm not shoving his
head down
okay
[Music]
again
back effortless okay and again why is it
effortless because I'm not pulling on
the extremities of the body I'm using
the initial
inertia to do this row I'm
not trying to pull someone bend them
over choreograph them to do the
technique okay um if you're doing the
Kon
one then you do have to have this arm
come up because this runs
out and you can't make it go behind
you so you do have to do the waiter's
hand so that you can stay positive on
that but guess what once you uh once you
get to the throw it has to now go to the
other shape and into it so you can't go
here
like you have to open up the technique
where it opens then you have the tech
okay
um we generally we do Kon nag every once
in a while but we generally just stick
with the regular versions okay they're
not something fancy for me like they are
for kadu
[Music]
um don't get trapped in Heaven and Earth
cuz you can you can smell the ego
tripartite mind it's so such a
simpleton two-dimensional obvious right
Heaven up Earth down do you know just
like K's breath and key tissues all this
um Heaven is not
it's not up it's not a place
okay that's really
stupid
um Heaven is a
contrast to the Earth which is a
contrast to heaven so you don't it
doesn't mean
verticality and then I also
know um that my cross has to spirally
rotate so there's no way it's in the two
dimensions of straight up and straight
down that's not going to work okay I
also know that I have only two spirals
so I can't be doing this kind of stuff
that that is not anything
okay
[Music]
um Heaven is associated with the inward
spiral and Earth is associated with the
outward spiral just like fire and water
is okay what Heaven and Earth are
signifying is very similar to Yin and
Yang or very similar to Fire and Water
it's the complet completion of the
system it has both sides of the spectrum
of possibilities that's what you're
doing and again what is important is
what's happening in the middle not at
the
extremities um so more reason not to try
to move your hands stay at the Grab
level and try to pull their extremities
the arm and the head okay work with
what's in the center what's in the
center is
invisible um is
intangible but real so the inertia is I
can't touch it but I can feel it okay um
that is the center of Heaven and Earth
there in their
Str uh also
um the UK do different things with their
hands
so if you see my hand go here it's
because in the breakfall that he's
taking he
he for me to keep my hand where it was
would have pulled on his shoulder okay
so if if he is going back you'll see my
hand go forward because you won't ever
see me pull this thing out okay so the
Hang is going to go forward as as he's
throwing but uh when I when you take it
all out the UK self preserves and lets
go of the of the grip but if they don't
it's the say let's say he's going back
no into the fall just do the
artificially civili
you you don't get pulled so you don't
pull this but you also don't make
yourself pullable by kind of just
simulate the fall and keep my grip or
keep your grip to try to pull me okay so
I don't try to go like
that and as he falls I also don't help
him up or help him from falling I don't
do that
but I also don't make myself pullable so
he pulls me down and I'm like that I
don't do that either okay so the first
thing you do is I don't pull on it and I
don't resist it I go with it so as he's
falling I go with it and I'll have him
try to grab me and I come
out because at the completion of the
outward spiral is the inward spiral so
as he takes the fall you're just out
that grip so sometimes you'll you'll see
that as this hand goes this way and then
it come it comes back on on me so that
it comes
out the opening of the grip okay but
you're not seeing me pull on the
shoulder pull on the shoulder or Force
any contestation at the grip even if you
see my hand go forward it's very similar
to my hand does go forward and down in
the inward spiral but it's not shoving
him it's staying with him okay it's
following him it's not pushing him
okay
e
e e